-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tom Hanks.
So we were talking about your
son Truman making his debut.
-Now, he got -- Marc Forster
wanted him because we resemble
each other almost exactly
from the age of 26.
-Yes.
But you -- This is not him.
This is you probably
around the age of 26.
This is your first film,
"He Knows You're Alone."
-Do you remember anything about
1980s, "He Knows You're Alone"?
-That was -- I played --
There was a -- There was a --
There was a psychotic killer
that was killing women
who were about to get married,
would-be brides.
-Uh-huh.
-And, by the way, that's my
own jacket,
and that's my own wardrobe.
[ Laughter ]
-It was January 1980
or something like that.
And somehow I got the part.
And I had to get up at 5:30 in
the morning and meet somebody
at 5:45 on the corner of, like,
9th Avenue and 43rd
to drive off to Staten Island
where we were shooting it.
And I vomited the morning
I got up, I was so nervous.
-Wow.
-I upchucked. I knew my --
I knew my dialogue,
but just the whole concept
of being in a movie
was terrifying.
-Now, when the agent called and
told you you have the part,
did they say,
"bring your own jacket"?
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
You know, it was like --
The movie cost like $400,000
or something like that.
They just said, "somebody will
call you,"
and thank God somebody did.
-I think this is the first time
I saw you on-screen,
was this film
"Mazes and Monsters."
-Oh, my God.
-Now, "Mazes and Monsters,"
by the poster, you think this is
a super cool sort of,
you know, "Lord of
the Rings"-type film.
[ Laughter ]
That is not the case.
-No. By the way, they gave me
some damn chiseled good looks
there.
-Yeah, they really --
-That's something else.
By the way, this was not
the billing when we made it.
-No, absolutely.
-It was on CBS.
Steven Stern directed.
Oh, yeah, Wendy Crewson.
She's fabulous.
She was in
"From the Earth to the Moon."
David Wallace. Lloyd Bochner,
who was a big deal.
Peter Donat. Chris Makepeace.
-Chris Makepeace is
in "My Bodyguard."
-"My Bodyguard," yeah.
It was about mazes -- kids
playing "Mazes and Monsters."
-Which was a Dungeons & Dra--
Yeah.
-No, no, Dungeons & Dragons.
-And you played a fella who got
so deep into the world
of Dungeons & Dragons --
-I began to see mazes
and monsters everywhere.
And I fled to New York City
and had a scene
on the top of
the World Trade Center.
-Really? This is a film that as
I watched as a kid,
it felt like a cautionary tale
to parents,
which was like, "Don't let your
kids play Dungeons & Dragons."
[ Laughter ]
-And did you?
-No, I didn't,
and here I still am.
-And here you are,
so let's -- let's --
We did the -- It had all
the gibberishy kind of names.
Beware of the Castle of
Thangoria.
And you shall go to
the Towers of Pabla--
You know, it's a little tough.
-Made it a little bit --
-But, look, I had a job.
I was the most thrilled guy
there was.
I was actually, I'm going to
say, 24 when I made that.
-Next time you're here, do I
have permission to introduce you
saying "you know him from
'Mazes and Monsters'"?
-I think.
[ Laughter ]
I think that is going to be
a requirement, I believe.
-You have a wonderful co-star
in this film,
which is this lovely --
I have a photo.
You have a lovely cat.
-Oh, yeah.
-Obviously you've worked with
dogs, children, volleyballs.
-Yes.
-How was --
[ Laughter ]
How was a cat co-star?
Same cat the whole movie?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
Smeagol. Smeagol Bagel.
You cannot train a cat to do
everything -- anything.
They are the most disinterested
creatures on the planet Earth.
Dogs will do exactly
what they are trained to do,
including look at you adoringly,
right?
Because you work with a dog
and the trainer says --
They say the word "bond,"
you know?
So the dog only looks at
the trainer all the time.
Just say "bond."
-Bond.
[ Laughter ]
-Then they come back.
That's literally what
they will do.
And you can even say
"bond sadder."
Say "bond sadder."
-Bond sadder.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-And then they will come back.
They have no idea
what they're doing.
But cats, cats are untrainable.
Cats lay around like this,
you know.
During the shot, the cat is
supposed to be in the bed.
The cat is supposed to be
sleeping.
The cat's like this.
[ Laughter ]
And this had to roll and roll
and roll because they wanted
a moment where the cat
looked at Otto.
And the cat eventually did this.
[ Laughter ]
And that was it.
-Do you ever have to sort of
have that awful moment
where you're, like,
waving something,
trying to get
the cat's attention?
-Oh, off-camera?
-Yeah.
Smeagol, Smeagol.
[ Clicking tongue ]
[ Laughter ]
Nothing. Nothing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But, now, is this true that
the cat was at the premiere?
-Yeah, we brought him along.
And he let me hold him again.
That was the big thing.
-Wow.
-Because literally that shot,
I had to hold him
for a couple hours.
And the cat has to decide
that you can hold him.
-Yeah.
-And you had to do it in
a very specific kind of way.
And, you know, you do
that kind of stuff.
And I was coached
for a long time.
And also the two trainers were
right there right off of camera.
And, yes, it's true no cat
was forced to do
any damn thing
it didn't want to
in the course of making
this motion picture.
-I would expect
nothing less of you, Tom Hanks.
-Held sway.
-Congratulations on the film.
It's always so lovely to have
you here. Thank you so much.
-Thank you. Thank you very much.
-Tom Hanks, everybody.
"A Man Called Otto"
is in theaters
everywhere on January 13th.
We'll be right back
with Jessie Buckley.
-Big winner.